associe tous les présidents des groupes
politiques
dans un premier temps elle a pour
objectif unique mais ô combien essentiel
d'effectuer un contrôle des mesures
prises au titre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'est à dire la gestion de la
crise sanitaire ainsi que la mise en
oeuvre des mesures de restriction des
libertés publiques
accompagnant le confinement c'est le
cycle que nous entamons aujourd'hui avec
vous monsieur le premier ministre vous
nous avez fait part sans tarder de votre
volonté que soit transmise à la
représentation nationale les
informations nécessaires à ce contrôle
comme le prévoit la loi
et je vous remercie de nous avoir d'ores
et déjà dresser un bilan
pratiquement en temps réel des premières
mesures que vous avez prises dans le
cadre de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
ce n'est que dans une seconde phase à
l'issue de la période de crise que le
champ des travaux de la mission sera
élargie à l'évaluation de la crise de
ses fondements et à ses conséquences
dans tous les secteurs économiques
budgétaires sociale culturelle et
internationale
c'est au cours de cette deuxième phase
que la mission pourra se voir confier
les prérogatives des commissions
d'enquêté qu'il sera amené à évaluer
l'impact des décisions prises par les
pouvoirs publics y compris sur une
période antérieure et a retiré les
enseignements de cette crise sans
précédent monsieur le premier ministre
je vais d'abord vous laisser la parole
puis nous vous poserons nos questions
ainsi qu'au ministre des solidarités de
la santé les conditions de la tenue de
cette réunion nous oblige à suivre une
certaine organisation pour qu'elle se
déroule dans de bonnes conditions
je vous propose que nous prenions les
questions de nos rapporteur 3 par 3 puis
par deux chaque session chaque séquence
pourra donner lieu de votre part à une
réponse groupe et une réponse de votre
part ou du ministre des solidarités et
de la santé
nous procéderons de même avec les
questions des collègues des groupes
politiques
nous enregistrons par quatre les
questions successives et nous vous
demanderons alors d'y répondre
je vous remercie de bien noter que
chacun disposera de deux minutes et pas
plus pour formuler sa question
il s'agit de notre première audition et
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
tous les sujets ne pourront pas être
abordée aujourd'hui
mais dès l'approché dès la semaine
prochaine nous procéderons également
l'audition de la garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice ainsi que du
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
premier ministre puisqu'il ne revient
d'ouvrir les débats
je souhaiterais me faire l'interprète de
la question centrale que se posent
beaucoup de nos compatriotes qui ont
compris l'entrée un état d'urgence
sanitaire
mais qui veulent pouvoir recevoir la
sortie sur quelles hypothèses
d'évolution de l'épidémie
construisez-vous l'action du
gouvernement et par conséquent comment
envisagez-vous progressivement la
reprise du cours normal de la vie
ma question ne vise pas vous demander
une date de sortie du confinement ce qui
serait absurde mais quelle trajectoire
d'évolution
pouvez vous nous décrire pour les
semaines à venir
y compris pour la mise en place des
différents tests notamment sérologique
ce premier ministre vous avez la parole
le président bonjour mesdames et
messieurs les députés
je nous vivons une crise sanitaire sans
précédent vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président est
je pense que chacun en a parfaitement
conscience peut-être avant de répondre à
la question que vous posez quelques
remarques
d'abord il est bien légitime et en
vérité extrêmement utile que dans une
période de crise le gouvernement puisse
être contrôlée par le parlement c'est le
coeur de la démocratie
et si j'ose dire c'est encore plus
important dans une période de crise où
les décisions sont lourdes à prendre où
elles ont un impact évident sur la ville
d'auch concitoyens et je voulais donc
vous dire que dans l'esprit que vous
avez indiqué nous sommes extrêmement
attentifs
le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement et moi-même à permettre ce
contrôle à être présents questions au
gouvernement
j insiste personnellement à transmettre
évidemment l'ensemble des décisions qui
sont prises dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire comme la loi nous
l'imposent à aller plus loin que la loi
en transmettant monsieur le président de
l'assemblée nationale et c'était
évidemment vrai également au sénat les
projets d'ordonnancé qui sont pris sur
le fondement de la loi du 23 mars mais
qui ne relèvent pas stricto sensu de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
nous vous transmettons avant même leur
adoption par le conseil des ministres
ces projets de façon à parfaire
l'information du parlement et je pense
qu'il ya là une pratique utile en ces
temps de crise
je ne sais pas si
le chef du gouvernement britannique où
le chef du gouvernement allemand n'ont
plus que le chef du gouvernement italien
ou celui du gouvernement espagnol
honteux devant les commissions haddock
ou permanente des parlements en question
des auditions comme celle à laquelle
nous nous livrons aujourd'hui mais je
pense que l'exercice est indispensable
j'avais envisagé de faire en préalable
une longue présentation à la fois des
faits sous une forme chronologique et
des enjeux de cette crise sanitaire
mais à vous entendre monsieur le
président et compte tenu du nombre
d'orateurs inscrits je crois qu'il est
préférable de limiter au maximum ce
propos introductif
je me contenterai donc si vous me
permettez de faire trois remarques très
brève
d'abord je vais évidemment essayer salon
évidemment essayer de répondre avec
olivier ferrand aux questions que vous
posez
je préfère dire les choses très
sincèrement et très clairement nous ne
savons pas tout
face à des événements de la nature de ce
que nous vivons
face au questionnement scientifique qui
sont en permanence poser face aux
conséquences de décisions telles que
celle du confinement qui n'ont pas été
prises seulement en france mais qui sont
prises dans beaucoup d'états comparables
nous ne savons pas tout et nous avons
pris le parti j'ai eu l'occasion
d'indiquer samedi en m'exprimant devant
les français de dire ce que nous savons
et de dire ce que nous ne savons pas
nous pouvons expliquer nos contraintes
nous pouvons expliquer nos décisions
mais je voudrais insister et je pense
que chacun peut le comprendre sur le
fait que les décisions que nous prenons
sont souvent prise sur le fondement
d'informations qui sont parfois
incomplètes et souvent contradictoires
peut-être que cela surprend ceux qui
nous écoutent mais c'est un fait
dans les périodes de crise plus encore
que dans les périodes de calme
les décisions prises par les autorités
politiques sont souvent pris sur le
fondement des informations incomplètes
et sont souvent prise sur le fondement
d'informations contradictoires
il est toujours beaucoup plus facile
d'apprécier l'opportunité de ces
décisions
une fois qu'on sait ce qui s'est passé
mais lorsqu'on prend les décisions
elles sont toujours prises dans les
conditions souvent prises dans les
conditions que je viens d'indiquer c'est
la première remarque je voulais faire
la deuxième remarque que je veux faire
c'est que nous sommes dans un combat un
combat contre un virus c'est un combat
long et qui va durer
c'est un combat difficile qui contiendra
ou qui impliquera des mauvaises
nouvelles
parfois des déceptions
lorsque nous pensons avoir atteint un
pic ou lorsque nous pensons avoir trouvé
une piste qui permettent d'apporter des
traitements c'est donc un combat dont je
ne veux caché à aucun de nos concitoyens
la dureté
ce que je peux assurer c'est que dans ce
combat je crois que c'est vrai de
l'ensemble des membres du parlement bien
entendu mais je vous en a testé pour les
membres du gouvernement nous opposons et
nous livrons un combat avec une volonté
farouche et un engagement total
toute notre énergie est consacrée à
lutter et à trouver les solutions les
plus adaptées
compte tenu des contraintes qui
s'imposent à nous la dernière remarque
je veux faire en préalable c'est que ce
combat il est mondial il est devenu
mondial nous vivons une situation unique
jamais la moitié de l'humanité où près
de la moitié de l'humanité n'a été
confinés jamais les économies des pays
les plus développés de ceux qui
contribuent le plus activement à la
production mondiale n'ont été
interrompus aussi brutalement aussi
largement jamais
aucun système de santé au monde n'a été
construit pensé dimensionné pour faire
face à ce que nous vivons
peut-être là posteriori faut-il le
regretter
peut-être sans doute faudra-t-il en
tirer les conséquences
mais il apparaît clairement qu'aucun
système de santé au monde n'a été conçu
pour faire face à une vague de cette
ampleur et il apparaît par surcroît que
l'ensemble des pays du monde sont
confrontés à cette vague en même temps
les deux phénomènes cumulé nous place
dans une situation parfaitement unique
et sans précédent
je peux attester devant la
représentation nationale qu'aucun
dirigeant d'aucun pays avec lesquels
nous avons pu entrer en contact
c'est vrai du chef du gouvernement c'est
vrai de chacun des ministres dans leur
champ de compétence c'est peut-être vrai
des parlementaires dans leurs contacts
avec d'autres parlementaires européens
voire internationaux qu'aucun
responsable ne prend la situation à la
légère et qu'aucun responsable ne peut
dire autre chose que sa grande
inquiétude et sa très grande
concentration il n'y a pas d'état où
l'on verrait les choses avec légèreté
il n'y a pas d'état où l'on verrait les
choses sans inquiétude
une fois que on a fait ces trois
remarques tout que j'ai fait cette
remarque préalable j'en viens à la
première question qui m'est posée et que
vous venez de me poser monsieur le
président sur
ce que nous avons commencé a désigné
sous le terme de déconfinement c'est à
dire la fin de la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
où les concitoyens nos concitoyens se
trouve confiné c'est à dire au fond sont
assujettis à un régime qui restreint
leur possibilité de sortir de chez eux
ils doivent rester chez eux
nous devons rester chez nous avec un
certain nombre d'exceptions
mais qui sont des exceptions une règle
générale qui s'impose à tous la question
que vous posez sur le dé confinement est
redoutablement complexe d'abord parce
que il n'y a pas de précédent
on n'a jamais confiné aussi largement
autant de gens et donc par définition
n'a jamais des confits des aussi
largement autant de gens n'y a pas de
process écrits de méthodes éprouvées et
le seul précédent qui existe celui qui a
été mis en application en chine pour la
région du hubei qui a été placé en
confinement pendant de longues semaines
est à lui seul un précédent qui n'est
pas totalement reproductible chez nous
puisque la chine entière n'étaient pas
placés en confinement mais seulement une
région plusieurs régions en l'occurrence
donc ce n'est pas comme s'il y avait une
méthode à suivre pour le déconfinement
le deuxième élément qui rend la question
la réponse à votre question délicat
c'est que le déconfinement va dépendre
dans sa réalisation d'éléments dont nous
ne disposons pas aujourd'hui entièrement
quelles sont ces éléments d'abord on
sent bien que le déconfinement sera
différent différence il existe au moment
du des confirmands des traitements et
prouver ou s'il n'en existe pas que la
réponse apportée à la question du
déconfinement pourra dépendre aussi de
notre capacité et je suis sûr que nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir à tester
et à tester quoi et attester qu'ils car
lorsqu'on parle des tests encore faut-il
savoir de quels tests l'ont pas et de
quelles capacités
on a à produire ces tests et à les
réaliser dans de bonnes conditions
7ce déconfinement dépendra aussi et je
parle sous le contrôle de d'olivier
ferrand qui est médecin lui ce que je ne
suis pas et ce que je ne prétends pas
être dépendra aussi de la façon dont le
virus aura circuler et donc de la
proportion de nos concitoyens qui ayant
été en contact avec le virus et ayant
développé des anticorps qui leur
permettre qui leur permettent d'avoir
une une immunisation immunité j'ai pas
comment il faut dire une immunisation
une immunisation combien quelle
proportion de françaises et de français
vont pouvoir disposer de cette
immunisation et donc comment le virus va
recommencer ou pourrait recommencer à
circuler ce qui est à peu près acquis à
ce stade c'est que nous avons décidé du
confinement en application d'une
stratégie que le ministre et moi-même
avons plusieurs fois expliqué qui
consiste à limiter le nombre de cas
sévères en essayant de faire en sorte
qu'ils ne dépassent pas les places
disponibles d'accueil dans les services
de soins intensifs et de réanimation
cet indicateur aussi longtemps qu'il n'y
a pas de traitement prouver pas de
vaccin reste évidemment un indicateur
décisif pour le déconfinement il est
donc probable jeudi probable et j'essaie
d'être précis dans mes mots probable que
nous ne nous acheminons pas vers un
déconfinement qui serait générale et
absolue en une fois partout et pour tout
le monde
encore une fois je dis c'est probable
nous avons nous demandé à plusieurs
équipes de travailler sur cette question
du déconfinement en étudiants
l'opportunité la faisabilité d'un
déconfinement qui serait régionaliser
oudin déconfinement qui serait sujet à
une politique de test et si oui laquelle
ou un déconfinement qui serait en
fonction qui sait de classe d'âge bref
nous sommes en train de travailler et
d'expertisé des scénarios en fonction
des hypothèses
ce que je crois utile de rappeler c'est
que d'abord la discussion sur ce
déconfinement devra avoir lieu
c'est une stratégie nationale qui
devrait être discutée présentés et
discutés et elle le sera
elle devra prendre en compte avant tout
des impératifs de santé protection de la
santé et nous espérons et là encore je
suis prudent dans les mots que j'utilise
nous espérons pouvoir avancer sur le
sujet et présenter des éléments d'une
stratégie de déconfinement dans les
jours et semaines qui viennent de façon
la semaine les jours qui viennent de
façon à pouvoir exposer et donner une
perspective à nos concitoyens car croyez
bien monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés que je mesure
parfaitement les contraintes qui pèsent
sur nos concitoyens la difficulté pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux à faire
face à cette période de confinement
difficulté qui n'est pas simplement un
inconfort qui peut être parfois
une vraie difficulté voir de vraies
menaces de vrais risques de raisin
quiétude
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'évoquer
ces risques ces inquiétudes à la fois
sur le plan sanitaire sur le plan
psychologique sur le plan des violences
qui peuvent être commises sur les femmes
sur les enfants à tous égards je mesure
bien les inconvénients et le risque qui
s'attache à une période de confinement
très ou trop longue mais je dis les
choses telles qu'elles sont nous sommes
en train de réfléchir de poser les
jalons de la réflexion d'étudier les
scénarii et nous avons besoin de
continuer à travailler pour exposer les
conditions dans lesquelles nous pourrons
organiser le déconfinement en
garantissant et en protégeant la santé
de nos concitoyens
première
monsieur woerth vous avez la parole
un essentiel mais la question ne portera
pas sur sur la santé elle sera posée par
mes collègues je voudrais d'abord vous
posez des questions sur le plan
économique il n'y a pas de confinement
économique en théorie mais il ya un
confinement économique en réalité et
l'urgence pour des confinés sur le plan
économique c'est évidemment qui est le
plus possible d'entreprises et d'emplois
qui résistent à cette crise j'ai donc
des questions très concrètes à vous
poser dans un premier temps parce que
l'urgence c'est celle ci en ce qui
concerne l'instruction par
l'administration de l'activité partielle
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya beaucoup de
difficultés pour accéder au site qui
permet cela j'ai le sentiment aussi que
parfois les l'instruction n'est pas la
même d'une région à une autre
que pourriez vous nous dire sur ce sujet
l'implication du secteur des assurances
on parle beaucoup d'assurance et non
républicain est mis en avant cela très
tôt à votre avis peut-on mieux impliquer
le secteur des assurances sans mettre en
danger sa solidité financière parce que
les assureurs doivent évidemment
continuer à assurer les autres risques
mais quel est votre sentiment
le troisième point c'est sur les prêts
qui sont garanties par la bpi et les
procédures d'octroi
avez-vous aujourd'hui des chiffres
concernant le montant des prêts qui est
effectivement été débloqués à ce stade
et n'y at il pas une complexité pour
utiliser ces prêts je crois que les
entreprises doivent s'adresser à leur
banque puis après doivent s'adresser à
la bpi ce n'est pas la banque qui
s'adresse donc comment cela se
passe-t-il enfin dernier point il ya des
intérêts derrière ces prêts pour les
renouvellements déchéance mais aussi
pour les prêts pour les prêts de
trésorerie
l'état ne devrait-il pas créer une sorte
de de ptz prêt à taux zéro corona virus
pour éviter que les entreprises ne ploie
sous les charges et soul et soûlé et
sous les intérêts
d'emprunts 7 il y a urgence je le sais
que voulez vous le savez l'opposition et
les républicains sont très mobilisés sur
ces thèmes-là sur la santé comme sur
l'économie et nous sommes évidemment
poursuivant les mêmes objectifs qui sont
ceux de sortir le plus vite possible de
cette crise tant sur le plan de la santé
la santé tous les français que sur le
plan bien sûr de la santé de nos
entreprises et nos emplois
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame brigitte bourguignon avant toute
chose et au nom des membres des affaires
sociales je tiens à m'associer à la
peine des familles frappées ces derniers
jours par la perte d'un parent d'un
enfant d'un an et demi ce moment
douloureux est d'autant plus difficile
que n ont pu en raison des règles
sanitaires de protection accompagner
leurs défunts dans ses derniers moments
dans cette épreuve sanitaire social et
que monique mais surtout humaine que
traverse ce pays qui affecte nos
compatriotes
il nous faut chers collègues faire
preuve d'humilité de dignité de
responsabilité
l'heure des enseignements à tirer de
cette crise viendra et la commission des
affaires sociales que je préside y
prendra sa part elle est d'ailleurs
d'ores et déjà en ordre de bataille pour
alimenter les travaux de la mission
d'information dans les champs de
compétence qui est le sien monsieur le
premier ministre
tout d'abord pour ma part je tiens à
saluer la réactivité avec laquelle votre
gouvernement a mis en place des
dispositifs essentiels pour protéger nos
compatriotes
quel que soit leur statut face aux
pertes de revenus liées à la situation
de crise à bon port nous savons tous à
quel point ce filet de protection est
fondamental pour surmonter les problèmes
je m'attacherai plus tôt aujourd'hui à
vous poser des questions sur le volet
sanitaire et social premièrement pouvez
vous nous indiquer si l'ensemble des
personnels soignants mobilisés en
première ligne à l'hôpital dans les
cabinets médicaux une médecin dispose
d'à ce genre et en quantité suffisante
du matériel de protection
deuxièmement pouvez vous faire un point
sur les capacités humaines et
matérielles d'accueil dans les services
de réanimation pays et nous prêts
6 et selon quelles modalités l'émission
des hôpitaux publics cliniques hôpitaux
privés s'articule tels quels sont les
projections surtout disponibles en
matière de tension sur ses capacités au
cours des prochains jours des prochaines
semaines
troisièmement enfin la situation dans
les ehpad a souvent été évoquée à juste
titre nos aînés sont les premières
victimes
mais il ne faudrait pas oublier les
établissements médico sociaux notamment
ceux accompagnant les enfants protéger
les personnes en situation de handicap
et surtout le front de l'aide à domicile
est essentielle à nos années parfois
isolés pour fille née à leur domicile
voyez vous nous préciser les mesures
spécifiques mis en oeuvre pour cette
catégorie de personnel et sa probité
morts la parade tout souvent hors au
système d localement permettez moi
monsieur le président de conclure en
continuant et en saluant le courage
l'abnégation de tous les soignants
je tiens également à saluer l'engagement
des travailleurs sociaux des auxiliaires
de vie qui poursuivent à leurs côtés
leurs actions auprès de nos compatriotes
les plus fragiles
malgré la crise qui frappe notre nation
allait prolonger leur action et plus
belles valeurs de la république et du
karité merci monsieur merci même la
présidente madame mauviel brawn pie v
prison de la commission des lois la
parole et co rapporteur pour deux
minutes
la santé comme vous le savez les 20 21
et 22 mars la commission des lois que
j'ai l'honneur de présider à travailler
sans relâche sur les deux textes dits
d'urgence pour lutter contre le
coronavirus nombreux sont les
parlementaires qui se sont impliqués
parfois à distance dans l'élaboration de
ces deux textes je voulais saluer à
nouveau l'esprit de responsabilité de
consensus qui a prévalu durant ce long
week end le parlement vous a alors
conférer de très larges prérogatives
pour faire face à l'épidémie
vous pouvez monsieur le premier ministre
afin de garantir la santé publique
restreindre ou interdire la circulation
des personnes et des véhicules interdit
aux personnes de sortir de leur domicile
ordonnait la fermeture d'établissements
recevant du public
interdire les rassemblements
réquisitionner des biens des services
des personnes
le parlement a souhaité que ses
prérogatives très large soit strictement
encadrée contrôlée et limitée dans le
temps
donc vous avez le rappeler que vous
aviez mis des mesures très strictes de
confinement à l'égard de toute la
population à compter du 17 mars
vous vous devez de veiller constamment
entre la conciliation des exigences de
santé publique et la protection des
libertés au premier chef celle d'aller
et venir
cette conciliation est une préoccupation
de tous les parlements et à cet égard je
voulais vous indiquer que j'étais en
contact avec mes homologues notamment du
parlement britannique
le président de l'assemblée nationale va
interroger sur le déconfinement je
voulais à cet égard vous poser des
questions par rapport aux libertés et à
la protection des données numériques
on entend parfois parler ou de tracking
sur les portables pour pouvoir procéder
aux déconfinement est ce que vous
envisagez de procéder de la sorte
par ailleurs comme vous le savez nous
avons adopté à l'unanimité un dispositif
de sanction graduée je voulais savoir si
vous pouviez nous récapituler les
chiffres des procès verbaux qui ont été
pris en application de ces sanctions est
par ailleurs pour terminer nos certains
représentants des forces de l'ordre
indique matériel de production
nécessaires alors sécurité sanitaire
quand ils effectuent des contrôles
pouvez vous nous préciser où on en est
de l'approvisionnement des masques à nos
forces de sécurité qui vont monter merci
madame la présidente monsieur de mini
monsieur le premier ministre
pardon sur ces questions de monsieur
woerth madame bourguignon et madame
brand pouvez vous avez la parole
monsieur le président je vais répondre
essayer en tout cas de répondre à la
question d'une question du président
woerth et de même la président brune
pilé et c'est olivier ferrand qui
répondra aux questions de madame la
présidente bourguignon pour répondre au
président woerth sur la dimension
économique bon d'abord je ne partage
évidemment avec lui
l'inquiétude et la conscience pleine et
entière des conséquences extrêmement
lourdes extrêmement lourde sur notre
pays du confinement de l'interruption du
cycle économique globale partout dans le
monde de la diminution considérable dans
des proportions à mon avis jamais
observé de la diminution de la demande
mondiale bref il est absolument certain
que à la crise sanitaire et susceptibles
de s'ajouter une crise économique et
peut-être demain une crise financière
mais en tout cas une crise économique
qu'il va falloir là aussi traversée est
dépassé c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a rapidement pris un
ensemble de mesures d'urgence que vous
connaissez monsieur le président puisque
le parlement les à voter après un débat
intense et je crois très très utile qui
se rassemblent au fond en deux grands
blocs la partie garantie d'emprunt
formulée par l'état qui permet aux
entreprises d'accéder à un financement
bancaire lequel est garantie par l'état
à hauteur de 300 milliards c'est
absolument indispensable si on veut que
la vie économique puisse se poursuivre
et puis 45 milliards d'euros
dead directe ou indirecte mais d'urgence
aux entreprises à travers les reports de
charges et les subventions directes
versées un certain nombre d'entreprises
dans des conditions que vous connaissez
je peux vous dire monsieur le président
que 1 des dispositifs que nous avons mis
en place c'est ce dispositif d'activité
partielle qu'on appelle parfois chômage
partiel mais quel immense intérêt de
préserver le lien entre le salarié et
l'entreprise donc de faire en sorte que
l'entreprise puis concert puisse
conserver auprès d'elle dans la
difficulté pour pouvoir le cas échéant
repartir ensuite une compétence une
expertise
une organisation le dispositif que nous
avons mis en place c'est un dispositif
qui n'existait pas jusqu'à présent nous
avons considérablement renforcé le
dispositif d'activité partielle en
veillant d'une part à ce qu'il ne à ce
qu'il ne soit pas seulement un
dispositif d'activité partielle qui
remplacerait le salaire partie du
salaire au niveau du smic mais qu'ils
aillent jusqu'à 4 5 smic pour faire en
sorte que dans les entreprises
ce soit une proportion beaucoup plus
large des salariés qu'ils puissent être
concerné par le régime d'activité
partielle et puis la deuxième chose
c'est que nous avons mis en place un
système qui est le plus généreux
d'europe c'est à dire qu'il permet aux
entreprises de ne pas subir les effets
économiques du régime du chômage partiel
est qu'il permet un taux de remplacement
pour le salarié qui est extrêmement
important qui est plus important même
que ce qui existe en allemagne à hauteur
de 84 % du salaire bien 337 milles
entreprises représentent 33,6 millions
de salariés on demandait et vont et
bénéficient aujourd'hui de ce régime
d'activité partielle c'est absolument
considérable c'est évidemment du jamais
vu et c'est un mécanisme qui a connu un
tel essor que c'est vrai vous avez
raison de le mentionner monsieur le
président veut un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui demandait en
bénéficier n'ont pas obtenu
immédiatement de réponse et ont dû
parfois attendre deux trois fois quatre
jours c'est vrai avant que leur
inscription à ce régime puissent être
confirmés
cela vient beaucoup du fait qu' on
n'avait jamais connu un tel afflux sur
un dispositif nouveau et donc il a fallu
le temps c'est vrai que l'ensemble de
ceux qui instruisent les dossiers
puissent améliorer l'outil informatique
et en tirer les conséquences
ces ajustements ont été faits nous
avions indiqué je crois que vous le
savez que les décisions serait
rétroactive ce qui permet au fond que
même si la décision est accordé quatre
cinq six jours après la demande
elle vient quand même entrer en vigueur
bien avant le moment où elle est
accordée et les transformations qui ont
été faites au système d'instruction me
laisse à penser nous
avons encore parlé ce matin avec la
ministre du travail que les inscriptions
et les décisions vont désormais se
prendre beaucoup plus vite vous poser
les questions sur les garanties en
évoquant le rôle de la bpi je voudrais
préciser pour ceux qui nous regardent
qui lie à la fois les prêts garantis par
la bpi et puis il ya le système garantis
par l'état et que l'ordre de grandeur
mais vous savez ça parfaitement monsieur
le président n'a rien à voir les prêts
garantis par la bpi 7 de l'ordre je
crois de 10 milliards d'euros les prêts
garantis par l'état dans le cadre du
mécanisme que nous avons créé ces de
l'ordre de 300 milliards d'euros
donc on est sur quelque chose qui
dépasse très largement par son ampleur
ce qui existait auparavant
là encore quelques chiffres au jour où
nous parlons ou peut être fière parce
que mes chiffres d'adp peut-être d'hier
vingt mille entreprises avaient demandé
des garanties d'emprunt pour des
emprunts à hauteur de 3 8 milliards
d'euros
et je crois pouvoir dire à ce stade que
300 millions ont déjà été accordés le
traitement de la demande doit
s'effectuer par les banques l'objectif
est de traiter ces demandes en cinq
jours
nous avons créé un système qui permet à
différé de remboursement d'emprunt au
bout d'un an et pendant 6 ans maximum
mais vous connaissez cet élément vous
posez des questions sur l'intérêt le
taux d'intérêt de 7 de cette garantie
d'emprunt qui pourrait être payé par
celui qui emprunte il n'est pas
totalement illégitime monsieur le
président que celui qui emprunte paye un
intérêt à celui qui prête même si
évidemment la garantie de cet emprunt
est accordée par l'état
je veux bien que on regarde le cas
échéant cette question en détail mais je
ne veux encore une fois je pense que
l'important c'est que le système
bancaire puisse faire son métier
plus forts de cette garantie et
continuer le financement des entreprises
enfin vous m'avez posé une question sur
les assurances il faut effectivement
mieux les impliquer sans que des
décisions qui pourraient sembler
généreuse en première analyse ne se
traduise infiné par l'écroulement du
système assurantiel car personne ne
gagnerait quoi que ce soit à
l'écroulement du système assurantiel en
france je sais que c'est tout à fait le
sens de votre question est que vous que
vous la cadrer bien et donc là encore
nous avons demandé aux assureurs de
venir participer abonder le fonds de
solidarité que nous avons créé de façon
à ce que l puisse nous aider à faire
passer l'épreuve à toute une série de
toutes petites entreprises
je sais que la question est souvent
posée de de l'indemnisation du préjudice
d'exploitation liés à la pandémie qui
n'entrent pas en général dans les
polices d'assurance y compris lorsque
l'on déclare l'état de catastrophe
naturelle
je pense que dans un premier temps et
dans le temps de l'urgence il est
indispensable de demander aux assureurs
aux assurances de mieux s'associer au
dispositif de financement que nous avons
créées elles l'ont fait à hauteur de 200
millions à ce stade
peut-être que au fil du temps puisque le
fonds en question est conduit à être
prolongée pour le mois d'avril peut-être
que elles seront plus généreuses en tout
cas nous les y inviterons et je sais que
il est en ce moment en train d'être
réfléchi à bercy des éléments qui
permettraient de toujours mieux associer
les assureurs au financement en question
voilà ce que je pouvais dire au
président woerth en espérant avoir
répondu à l'ensemble de ces questions
pour madame la présidente
brand privé c'est vrai l'état d'urgence
sanitaire offre des plus exactement
permet au gouvernement de prendre des
mesures qui doivent toujours respecter
cette conciliation entre protection
sanitaire et respect des libertés
j'y suis évidemment très sensible
vous me demandez le chiffre
les chiffres d'application des sanctions
qui ont été prises jusqu'à présent je
veux vous dire madame la présidente
qu'entre le 17 et le 30 mars 2020 ce
sont près de 5 8 millions de contrôles
qui ont été opérées sur le territoire
national et plus de trois cent cinquante
neuf mille infractions qui ont été
relevées dont me dit-on 64% pour la
police nationale
vous le savez nous avons prévu un
durcissement des sanctions par la loire
les amendes infligées peuvent aller
jusqu'à 1500 euros en cas de réitération
de l'infraction
dans les quinze jours quatre violations
dans un délai de trente jours pourrait
constituer constitue un délit que le
juge pourra punir d'une peine allant de
6 mois d'emprisonnement à 3750 euros
d'amande et l'accompagner d'une
suspension de permis de conduire c'est
donc évidemment des décisions très
lourdes qui sont susceptibles d'être
prises je sais que beaucoup de questions
sont posées sur le discernement donc
évidemment les autorités doivent faire
preuve dans l'application de ces
sanctions jeudi les autorités car la
police nationale la gendarmerie et
depuis peu les polices municipales
peuvent faire appliquer enfin appliquer
ces dispositifs
c'est évidemment une question sensible
celle du discernement puisque il faut
qu'à chaque instant
l'ensemble des forces qui sont amenés à
faire respecter ces dispositions
comprennent et applique le principe d'un
confinement général exigeant et en même
temps respecte la possibilité les
possibilités qui sont offertes à nos
concitoyens d'aller travailler d'aller
faire des courses quand c'est nécessaire
de pouvoir se rendre chez son médecin
pour des questions de santé lorsque les
les soins font l'objet d'une
programmation le casier chien ou en tout
cas d'une convocation
lorsque il est indispensable d'aller se
faire soigner
bref il y a beaucoup de question
d'appréciation sur le moment j'en suis
parfaitement conscience est un régime
délicat le ministre de l'intérieur
moi-même répétant systématiquement le
plus souvent aux forces de l'ordre
qu'elles doivent faire preuve de
discernement d'exigence mais de
discernement est évidemment dans ces
moments vous avez évoqué la question du
tracking
c'est à dire au fond la possibilité en
utilisant les technologies les plus
avancées de suivre les déplacements et
le cas échéant les rencontres et les
croisements de quelqu'un c'est sur le
fondement de ces tracking qu'un certain
nombre de pays
honteux procéder à l' isolement très
stricte de ce qui était malade et de ce
qu'ils avaient pu entrer en relation
avec quelqu'un qui aurait été malade ces
dispositifs en france n'existe pas parce
qu'ils ne seraient pas légalement permis
chacun en a parfaitement conscience
on pourrait peut-être et je dis
peut-être madame la présidente car le
débat n'est évidemment pas clos on
pourrait peut-être sur le fondement d'un
engagement volontaire utiliser ces
méthodes pour mieux tracer la
circulation du virus et les contacts
réalisés par quelqu'un qui serait qui
saurait qu'il est qu'il est les contacts
de chacun mais mais nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui et nous n'avons pas d'
instrument légal et nous ne travaillons
pas aujourd'hui sur des instruments qui
rendrait obligatoire ce tracking la
question peut être posée de savoir si il
pourrait être volontaire et et produire
des effets dans ce cas c'est une
question qui est à ce stade encore
ouverte voilà pardon j'ai pris du temps
pour répondre j'espère que j'ai évoqué
toutes les questions je vais laisser la
parole à olivier ferrand sur les
questions posées par un homme la
présidente bourguignonne monsieur le
ministre solidarité de la santé pour les
questions de la présidente brigitte
bourguignon dit monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
bonsoir madame la présidente brigitte
bourguignon merci pour vos questions
j'en compte trois grandes je vais
essayer de vous faire une réponse à la
fois synthétique est la plus exhaustive
possible
la première question que vous posez
porte sur la protection des soignants
c'est une question cruciale fondamentale
qui est au coeur des politiques de ce
ministère depuis le premier jour et même
avant le premier jour de l'épidémie nous
n'avons jamais caché les difficultés
auxquelles la france mais également
l'ensemble des pays du monde font face
en matière de matériel de protection
puisque tous les pays du monde se sont
trouvés au même moment
confrontée à des besoins exceptionnels
en matériel de protection quand je dis
exceptionnel c'est qu'on a parfois des
consommations par exemple de masques
dans certains hôpitaux qui font face à
des pics épidémiques de l'ordre deux
fois ce soit 20 x 20 x la consommation
normale et tous ces pays au monde se
sont tournés vers le pays principal
producteur la chine dont les usines
étaient fermés depuis plus de deux mois
puisque cette même chine avait été
confronté de plein fouet à l'épidémie
avant nous nous n'avons jamais caché les
difficultés nous avons toujours
communiqué en transparence les chiffres
exhaustifs de masques de protection ffp2
et chirurgicaux dont la france dispose
le fameux stocks d'état et nous avons
présenté à plusieurs reprises les
modalités avec lesquelles nous avions
déstocker et au nous distribuions ces
matériels de protection sur le
territoire en respectant quelques règles
je le reste mais je les rappelle
privilégiez les territoires les plus
hautes tensions là où le virus circule
le plus est également assuré qu on
puisse offrir de la protection à
l'ensemble des soignants ce pays mais
également aux patients les plus fragiles
vous dire que nous avons des stockés
depuis le début de l'épidémie plus de
110 millions de masques
nous estimons les besoins actuels avec
la doctrine de répartition à 40 millions
de masques hebdomadaire et une nouvelle
livraison de masques de l'ordre de 40
millions partir à destination des
pharmacies d'officine à destination des
établissements de santé des ehpad des
auxiliaires des personnes qui
interviennent au domicile mais également
d'autres professions de première ligne
parmi lesquels les pompiers les
éducateurs spécialisés
les personnes qui travaillent en
hébergement d'urgence cette semaine pour
vous donner une indication nous avons
renforcé notre stock de l'ordre de 28
millions de masques donc nous avons
consommé 40 millions et fait rentrer 28
millions de masques 8 millions par une
production nationale
le reste relevant de dons et
d'importation s'agissant des
importations le pont aérien qui a été
mis en place entre la france et la chine
a permis d'importer lundi 8 5 millions
de masques
nous en attendons 13 millions de masques
supplémentaires la semaine prochaine et
au total je le rappelle la france a
passé une commande pour plus d'un
milliard et demi de masques en france et
à l'étranger un milliard et demi
nous n'avons pas caché non plus les
difficultés liées au fait qu entre la
commande la production et l'arrivée sur
le territoire français il y avait des
étapes extrêmement complexe du fait
d'une compétition mondiale sur
l'ensemble de ses matériels de
protection mais je le redis la france
anticiper ses commandes nous avions
passé les premières d'entre elles avant
même que les usines de production et
rouvert leurs portes
cela dit je comprends parfaitement le
désarroi les attente très forte des
professionnels de santé sur l'ensemble
du territoire je les remercie infiniment
pour leur action au service des malades
dans des conditions que je sais
exceptionnellement difficiles et les
difficultés en matière de matériel de
protection sont une difficulté de plus
face à un afflux de malades comme la
france n'a jamais connu vous dire
également que nous avons distribué 300
milles blues et 100000 surblouse à
destination prioritairement des régions
les plus touchées par l'épidémie
cette semaine deuxième cadre de
questions vous posez fondamentale la
question des réanimations pour que
chacun puisse se rendre compte de la
situation alors à laquelle je vous parle
il ya plus de 5500 malades du
coronavirus hospitalisés dans des
réanimations française à titre de
comparaison la france compte en
situation normale
5000 lits de réanimation c'est à dire
qu'il ya plus de malades aujourd'hui en
réa malades du coronavirus que la france
compte traditionnement de
traditionnellement de lits de
réanimation pourquoi
parce que le plan blanc qui a été
activée très tôt la déprogrammation de
toutes les activités dans les hôpitaux
et les cliniques privées a permis
d'augmenter nos capacités de réanimation
à dix mille lits et nous sommes en train
de continuer à les augmenter
avec un effort phénoménal dans le grand
est notamment en ile de france notamment
en bourgogne franche comté en corse des
augmentations que nous n'en avions
jamais connue dans notre pays pour
atteindre un objectif qui est un
objectif
je le rappelle de l'ordre de 14 mille
lits de réanimation pour vous donner des
informations exhaustives
il reste à date ce soir 4000 lits sur le
territoire national disponibles dont
1700 lits dédiés qu'ovide 19
ça implique systématiquement encore une
fois des efforts de structuration de
réorganisation avec des procédures ou
transformer des blocs opératoires
réanimation vous n'imaginez même pas ce
que les équipes sont capables de
réaliser comme comme exploit sur les
territoires je remercie aussi les
équipes des agences régionales de santé
extrêmement mobilisés pour arriver à
réaliser tout cela pour tendre le cou
encore une fois une rumeur le secteur
privé est lui aussi pleinement mobilisés
partout où le virus circule le président
de la fédération hospitalière privée
laminé gharbi est d'ailleurs fait un
communiqué très clair sur ce sujet hier
matin en expliquant que partout il était
nécessaire que les cliniques participent
à l'effort de guerre elle le faisait
cela étant vous avez des territoires sur
notre sur notre territoire national des
régions dans lesquelles le virus circule
moins et dans ces territoires
eh bien les réanimations publiques comme
privées ne sont pas nécessairement
totalement mobilisés mais si besoin
était elles le seront
je rappelle également qu'au delà du fait
d'armes et de nouveaux lits de
réanimation mais peut-être que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en parler cela fait
appel à la réserve sanitaire à du
matériel de respirateurs le président la
république annoncé hier une commande
pour 10000 respirateur supplémentaire et
ça fait aussi appel à des enjeux en
termes de médicaments de réanimation
nous n'avons jamais réalisé autant
d'évacuations sanitaires dans notre pays
que depuis quinze jours par train par
avion par hélicoptère par bateau par
ambulance en france comme à l'étranger
et je salue la mobilisation de nos
voisins allemands
néanmoins la situation reste extrêmement
tendue extrêmement difficile notamment
dans le grand est et en ile de france
nous avons d alerte permanente nous
sommes en permanence en contact étroit
avec les élus locaux
très mobilisés dans ces territoires avec
les directions d'hôpitaux avec les
médecins et nous faisons le maximum pour
augmenter les évacuations et augmenter
les capacités d'accueil mais mesdames et
messieurs les députés la situation était
extrêmement tendue je le redis il ya ce
soir
450 patients de plus en réanimation qui
hier nous sommes toujours sur une
trajectoire de dynamique épidémique
extrêmement grave et inquiétante
dernier sujet que vous avez abordé
madame la présidente
le sujet des ehpad j'ai réuni hier
l'ensemble des acteurs qui travaillent
dans le domaine des ehpad et des soins à
domicile
je leur ai présenté les filières de
soins spécifiques destinés aux personnes
âgées à domicile ou en ehpad travaillé
au sein de sacs de chaque territoire de
santé en lien avec les ars
je leur ai également présenté les
mesures de confinement au delà du plan
bleu que nous avons activé il ya
plusieurs semaines pour protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles le secteur
médico-social du handicap n'est pas du
tout oublié nous travaillons avec la
secrétaire d'état sophie cluzel et nous
aurons une communication conjointe d'ici
à la fin de la semaine sur ce sujet et
enfin le secteur qui je sais vous est
chère madame la présidente de la
protection de l'enfance
travailler aussi avec beaucoup
d'attention notamment par les
secrétaires d'état de mon ministère
adrien taquet et christelle du boss et
nous sommes en lien permanent avec les
acteurs de ce domaine fondamental
je remercie merci monsieur le ministre
il y à 21 collègues qui fait de vous
interroger
je vais donc donner la parole à madame
marielle de sarnez
ensuite monsieur lescure ensuite
monsieur stud air madame de sarnez la
parole si monsieur le président mes
premiers mots seront pour nos
concitoyens ceux qui souffrent ceux qui
luttent pour leur vie sous qui soigne
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes à leurs
côtés
la crise que nous vivons c'est une prise
planétaire c'est l'humanité tout entière
qui est touchée cette épidémie elle pose
à l'union européenne la grande question
de sa vocation
nous sommes inquiets des premières
réponses et des manquements qu'elle
révèle l'italie mais aussi l'espagne ont
été laissés très seul en première ligne
on a comme d'habitude la pression que
c'est le chacun pour soi qui lampard
pour nombre d'états jacques delors l'a
rappelé le manque de solidarité peut
être mortelle pour l'europe
trois questions se posent la première
c'est celle de l'indépendance de notre
union
face au risque de pénurie de médicaments
de matériel de protection sanitaire et
dans tous les domaines stratégiques
vitaux nous avons le devoir de garantir
à notre ensemble politique les moyens de
son indépendance et de sa souveraineté
ensuite pour affronter la crise
sanitaire empêcher l'effondrement de nos
économies et de notre modèle social de
nouvelles dépenses publiques seront
indispensables il n'y aura pas d'autre
issue que de le faire ensemble
enfin notre solidarité et notre
responsabilité doivent s'étendre à nos
voisins à nos proches
je pense en particulier au continent
africain que nous savons si menacée
pouvez vous nous dire monsieur le
premier ministre sur ces trois sujets
d'inquiétude comment la france peut
entraîner l'europe pour être à la
hauteur
de ce qu'exige ce moment clé de
l'histoire du monde je vous remercie
merci mme la présidente de la clarté la
concision de votre question monsieur le
présent lescure vous avez la parole
merci ça a été dit à certains de nos
collègues évidemment la priorité absolue
en france en tout cas elle a été définie
c'est la santé des français c'est pas le
cas partout on a des débats dans
d'autres pays pour un arbitrage éventuel
entre l'économie et la santé je dois
féliciter diamanka santé soit la
priorité des priorités
mais derrière vient la priorité
économique avec une récession qui
s'annonce profonde et un risque
évidemment cette récession non seulement
confiance à nos durable sur le dépens en
place toutes les mesures pour soutenir
l'économie
ce pack vous l'avez dit vous l'avez dit
il nous avons voté un plan de relance
importants à quand soutient plutôt
important qui a deux priorités
essentielles maintenir le maximum de
gens en emploi avec l'activité partielle
et éviter au maximum les défaillances
d'entreprises faut que les françaises et
les français sachent que c'est pas le
choix qui a été fait partout aux états
unis en une semaine on a des milliers de
défaillances d'entreprises et des
millions de chômeurs en plus là où en
france on a souhaité préserver ce filet
social
on a réuni la la commission des affaires
économiques ce matin il ya deux trois
questions qui se posent que je voulais
vous nous transmettre la première ça a
été mentionnée par le président vert
c'est le rôle du secteur de l'assurance
évidemment le secteur de l'assurance ne
peut pas tenir tout seul à bout de bras
l'économie française mais il est
important qu'il joue son rôle et qui
joue son rôle pleinement pour soutenir
notamment les très petites entreprises
2 je sais que vous adaptez votre
dispositif en continu monsieur le
communiste pouvait vous nous confirmer
que le seuil pour avoir accès aux fonds
de solidarité pour les très petites
entreprises et bien de 50% de baisse du
chiffre d'affaires je sais que vous avez
eu beaucoup d' alerte sur ce plan là de
la part d'entreprises et de la part de
parlementaires de terrain et donc on a
bien un seuil de 50% qui donnera lieu à
un accès à ce fonds de solidarité pour
les très petites entreprises à la fois
pro
avril est aussi pour le mois de mars
outre activement troisième question très
importante
il ya des entreprises qui ont vu leur
valeur fondre notamment en bourse
nous sommes préoccupés nous sommes
inquiets par le fait que certains
acquéreurs des fonds vautours des
investisseurs financiers pourrait venir
faire leur marché en france donc avait
voix en tête monsieur le premier
ministre pour soutenir les entreprises
françaises qui ne doivent pas évidemment
lettres victimes d'opérations alors ou
agressif merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président stud r merci
monsieur le président je ne sais pas
merci monsieur le président je dois les
droits mais question qui intéresse
nombre de nos concitoyens parce qu'elles
ont un rapport avec l'éducation d'abord
sur le calendrier
monsieur le premier ministre le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a annoncé une possible rentrée
des classes le 4 mai alors au delà de la
date elle même qui va déjà bien au delà
de la prolongation du confinement que
annoncé jusqu'au 15 avril
au delà de la date elle même sur quels
critères avez-vous la décision de
rouvrir les établissements de sucre
c'est aussi une question de calendrier
qui me permettra de faire le lien avec
mon deuxième point que la continuité
pédagogique
comment envisagez-vous celle ci alors
que vendredi la première zone va rentrer
en vacances n'aurait-il pas fallu
uniformiser les trois périodes de
vacances alors même que la pression sur
les enfants et leurs parents est forte
depuis le début du confinement
quelle qu'ait été la date de rentrée
après les vacances d'hiver
c'est ce qui me permet de vous poser la
question du sens mais surprise la
continuité pédagogique mise en oeuvre
pour lui dire de façon remarquable par
les fonctionnaires de l'éducation
nationale professeur personnels de
direction dans l'inspection autres
personnels cette continuité pédagogique
peut-elle être autre chose que de la
revue révision et l'approfondissement
des acquis cette question se pose alors
même que le sens de l'éducation
nationale et d'avancer tous ensemble et
que l'on sait que de très nombreux
élèves les familles ne sont pas ou très
peu connecté avec et que les chiffres
avancés par le ministére hier 5 à 8 %
d'élèves père du cache sans aucun doute
des réalités très différentes avec des
taux de connexions très très faible pour
certains publics
cela nous amène monsieur le premier
serait également une autre question
importante qu'il organise une
baccalauréat ne faudrait-il pas
privilégier les jours de cours au jour
d'examen et le contrôle continu ne
peut-il pas 17 dès cette année être
appliquée aux candidats et pour les
élèves de première qui sont les premiers
à passer le baccalauréat dans sa
nouvelle formule
les épreuves de contrôle continu ne
doivent elles pas être allégés et
simplifiés par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
constater au mois de février sur la
première vague de cette fois c'est enfin
ce prêt ministre le numérique et
pédagogiquement une opportunité au delà
d'être un moyen de répondre alors c'est
une coalition je veux ici d'ailleurs
salué au passage de l'audiovisuel public
notamment france 4 je pense qu'à la
fermeture ne peut plus être d'actualité
et la plateforme unis mais au delà
monsieur le ministre comment ne pas
s'interroger sur le fait que cette crise
révèle à nourrir éducatif qui n'est pas
national il nous faudra voir dans ses
yeux vo ministre oui pour que tout le
monde puisse gestion et mais dans le
temps qui est un parti en mai dernier
vous avez la parole monsieur le premier
ministre les i merci monsieur le
président et je vais commencer par
répondre au président ce tuner jeu
bon il y aurait énormément de choses à
dire sur les questions d'éducation et je
vais être pris par le temps donc je
voudrais aller droit au but n'ont pas
mais essayez d'expliquer nos contraintes
d'abord le ministre de l'éducation
nationale quand il a évoqué la date de
début mai l'a évoqué comme une hypothèse
alors je sais que dans le débat public
aujourd'hui quand on parle d'une
hypothèse assez vite ça devient une
certitude voir une annonce la vérité
c'est que c'est une hypothèse
nous aimerions pouvoir recommencer et
travailler sur cette hypothèse d'une
réouverture des établissements scolaires
le au début du mois de mai mais bien
entendu cette question est lié à la
question générale du déconfinement et
des conditions dans lesquelles nous
allons pouvoir procéder à ce
déconfinement je vous renvoie aux
éléments de réponse que j'ai donné au
président ferrand au début de mon
intervention
la continuité pédagogique la continuité
pédagogique est à la fois nécessaire et
en même temps très difficiles nous
savons tous bien les professeurs le
savent mieux que quiconque que l'art
d'enseigner ce n'est pas simplement
l'art de transmettre des connaissances
par par l'intermédiaire d'un écran ou
même en tête à tête dans l'art
d'enseigner il y a l'émulation d'une
classe et d'un groupe il y à la façon de
réagir à ce que disent d'autres c'est un
travail collectif l'enseignement par
classe et c'est indispensable
nous sommes confrontés à une situation
qui n'a pas de précédent de confinement
nous ne pouvons pas rien faire et il est
indispensable préférable que les
enseignants puissent continuer à faire
travailler les leurs élèves à leur faire
lire à vérifier que les connaissances
peuvent être acquises le cas échéant à
vérifier que il procède bien des
exercices
ah bon je dois dire monsieur le
président ce tuner que comme vous je
suis très impressionné par la très
grande inventivité par la très grande
motivation que beaucoup d enseignants de
ce pays démontre dans la façon de faire
travailler des enfants et dans cette
méthode dans un environnement dégradé de
poursuivre leur mission
c'était tout à fait admirable et nous
avons tous autour de nous des exemples
très impressionnant avec évidemment des
choses qui se mettent au point
beaucoup ont souligné le fait que au
début ils soient des problèmes
techniques soient trop de travail donné
à certains élèves soient trop de travail
donné en même temps aux mêmes élèves
bref on est en train de se caler mais il
ya néanmoins quelque chose qui n'est pas
parfait mais qui est assez exceptionnel
en terme d'engagement je veux le
souligner à la suite de ce que vous avez
dit c'est l'idée de la continuité
pédagogique
les vacances vont arriver il n'est pas
question alors même que le confinement
lui va demeurer
il n'est pas question de dire que les
vacances n'aurait pas lieu d'être
les professeurs travaillent en ce moment
il travaille souvent de chez eux
enfin il travaille en ce moment certains
se sont engagés volontairement à venir
garder les enfants des soignants dans
les écoles il faut que ce travail puisse
interrompre pour les professeurs et pour
les élèves
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on passe des
vacances sans complètement travailler
tout le monde sait bien que quand
l'école est réalisée normalement il peut
arriver que des professeurs donne des
devoirs pendant les vacances à leurs
élèves
je n'invente rien en disant cela on peut
imaginer la même chose mais il est
important de préserver cette période de
vacances pour le repos des esprits et
pour pouvoir recommencer ensuite dans de
bonnes conditions
vous connaissez le questionnement qui se
posent sur le baccalauréat organisées le
baccalauréat
c'est quelque chose de massif tous les
gens qui participent à l'organisation du
baccalauréat savent que chaque année
c'est un exercice considérable
d'impression de définition des sujets
c'est une énorme machinerie qui prend
beaucoup de temps et qui commence très
tôt le confinement rentrée délicate
l'organisation dans des conditions
normales du baccalauréat très délicat
matériellement et j'allais dire très
délicat presque
comment dire pédagogiquement puisque par
définition les conditions d'enseignement
sont dégradées réel et encore une fois
je te salue le l'engagement des
enseignants mais dégradé par rapport à
ce qui est la norme et donc il nous
paraît je le dis parce que j'en ai
beaucoup discuté avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pendant toute la
semaine il nous paraît délicat
d'imaginer que l'on puisse faire comme
si de rien n'était et imaginer que le
bac ce 2020 2020 se passerait dans des
conditions normales je ne crois pas aux
jours où nous parlons qu'il puisse se
passer dans des conditions normales
comme si de rien n'était il n'est pas
raisonnable d'imaginer cela il faut donc
étudier et c'est ce qui est en train
d'être fait par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale les conditions
dans lesquelles le bac 2020 peut être
organisé
plusieurs options sont sur la table il y
a ceux qui disent organisons le parent
contrôle continu et assumons le fait que
cette année c'est le contrôle continu
qui doit prévaloir
entièrement il ya ceux qui disent
essayons de conserver la possibilité
d'organiser une épreuve beaucoup d'idées
sont réunis beaucoup d'idées sont
formulés beaucoup de contraintes
s'applique à nous il est bien évident
que cette question est assez fortement
liée aux conditions dans lesquelles nous
allons procéder aux déconfinement et
donc est soumise à beaucoup d'inconnues
celle que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
le ministre est en train avec ses
services de consulter et d'instruire les
solutions qui sont envisageables et
j'aurai l'occasion avec lui de
m'exprimer prochainement pour dire quel
est le sens de la décision que nous
prenons
mais vous imaginez bien que il est
désormais acquis qu'il ne sera pas
possible d'organiser dans les conditions
normales le bac 2020 enfin vous avez
souligné par un mot l'engagement de
france 4 et donc l'engagement du service
public en matière audiovisuelle et
singulièrement à la télévision pour
essayer d'apporter un service
supplémentaire à destination des des
élèves et je salue moi aussi cet
exercice parce qu'il est il est très
bien réalisé je crois est très utile
le président lescure a parlé des risques
économiques il a évoqué la question de
l'assurance je n'y reviens pas il a
évoqué la question du seuil à partir du
seuil de perte de chiffre d'affaires à
partir duquel les petites entreprises
les tpe pme pourraient bénéficier du
fonds de solidarité que nous avons créé
sa fonds de solidarité à hauteur de 1
milliard 2 200 millions versée par les
assureurs 250 millions sur lesquels les
régions se sont engagés et donc
participeront au fond et puis le reste
garantie est versée par l'état
nous avons pris la décision après avoir
beaucoup écouté à la fois les
parlementaires et bien sûr les
entreprises et les corps intermédiaires
de faire en sorte que puissent
bénéficier de cette subvention de ce
versement à la fois les entreprises qui
par décision publique ont été fermés je
pense évidemment au bar au restaurant tu
ne peuvent plus exercer leurs activités
depuis le 15 mars
et toutes les entreprises qui auront vu
leur chiffre d'affaires baisser de 50 %
initialement nous avions envisagé 70%
nous avons fait en sorte que le seul
puisse être abaissé à 50% pour le mois
de mars il sera évidemment conservé à
50% pour le mois d'avril donc je voulais
vous confirmez monsieur le président
lescure le sens de cette décision enfin
pour la protection des entreprises
françaises qui pourraient se voir
attaquer dans leur capital par une
dévalorisation de ma part une baisse de
leurs valorisations boursières notamment
et qui pourrait donc être l'objet de
raids ou d'achats massifs par des angles
des investisseurs étrangers souverain ou
nos souverains mais qui présenterait un
risque
nous avons un dispositif assez complet
dont vous savez qu'il a d'ailleurs été
complétée par la loi pacte de contrôle
des investissements étrangers en france
ce dispositif va évidemment fonctionné
et appelé à fonctionner nous sommes
extrêmement vigilants sur son
application
il a été étendu par la loi pas que vous
savez à de nouveaux secteurs avec de
nouveaux instruments nous les mettrons
en oeuvre s'il le faut et j'ai indiqué
que nous étions prêts dons que nous
étions évidemment dans l'état d'esprit
d'utiliser toutes les prérogatives qui
sont celles de l'état à la fois dans les
entreprises où l'état est déjà
actionnaire à près de 90 entreprises
dans lesquelles déjà l'état est déjà
actionnaire et dans lesquelles l'état
jouera son rôle et prendra ses
responsabilités et le cas échéant dans
des entreprises dont l'état n'est pas
actionnaire mais qui pourrait
représenter un intérêt souveraineté
nationale nous avons indiqué que nous
serions prêts à prendre nos
responsabilités et je redis ici cette
totale et farouche volonté
enfin madame la présidente sarnez a
évoqué la question
européenne
à la fois de fonctionnement de la
solidarité européenne à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne à l'extérieur
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
et la question de la relance économique
qui devrait intervenir un mot pour dire
d'un point de vue général que la
solidarité et la réaction européenne ont
été réels ont-elles été suffisante
ont-elles été suffisante c'est une
question que tous ceux qui attendent
beaucoup de l'europe sont en droit de se
poser et se poseront évidemment et qui
va nourrir le débat politique et les
transformations et les évolutions qui ne
manqueront pas d'intervenir parce que
nous tirerons les enseignements de cette
crise je voudrais dire souligné que la
réponse européenne a été réelle je le
dis on peut toujours se poser la
question de savoir si ça a été suffisant
mais elle a été réelle la réponse
sanitaire avec un appel à projet de
financement de la recherche sur des
vaccins avec la création d'une réserve
stratégique en matière médicale avec le
lancement par la commission de 4 marchés
conjoint d'achat d'équipements qui
permettait de groupe et des commandes et
qui évidemment peuvent avoir un effet la
réponse européenne à l'acte et réelle
sur le plan économique avec des mesures
de soutien à l'économie mobilisation de
37 milliards d'euros via le fonds de
cohésion qui n'avait pas été consommés
et qui ont du coup été relâchés ce qui
est évidemment quelque chose d'important
laplane flexibilité reconnu s'agissant
du régime des aides d'état l'union
européenne a dit dans ce moment de crise
les règles sur lesquelles la commission
exercer un contrôle parfois jugée
tatillon par l'ensemble des états
considéré qu'il fallait évidemment
relâcher le contrôle pour pouvoir donner
des marges de manoeuvre très large aux
états c'est la suspension des règles
budgétaires et de déclenchement de la
clause dérogatoire générale qui l'a
aussi donne de l'aide de l'espace aux
états pour gérer leur réponse budgétaire
ça a été aussi l'adaptation de la
législation en matière de transport
aérien et d'autres mesures qui ont été
prises collectivement qui ne sont pas
forcément spectaculaire mais qui ont été
très utiles à la fois pour la gestion du
transport aérien pour l'importation des
produits médicaux bref des choses qui
existent je voudrais aussi souligner le
rôle de la banque centrale européenne
qui évidemment est une institution de
nature un peu particulière mais qui a
très fortement réagi le 18 mars avec le
programme de soutien d'urgence d'un
montant de 750 milliards d'euros qui a
considérablement détendue les marchés
financiers ce n'est pas que j'aime
particulièrement les marchés financiers
ni que je les déteste c'est que si les
marchés financiers s'étaient mis en
croix où avait commencé à dysfonctionner
alors l'impact pour le monde économique
or et était plus fort et plus brutale
encore de ce point de vue il faut saluer
la réponse de la banque centrale
européenne enfin s'agissant de don
d'équipements médicaux d'accueil de
patients d'opérations de retour et de
rapatriement il y à une solidarité
européenne
nous avons nous la france ramener des
compatriotes plus exactement des
concitoyens européens notamment depuis
la chine
au début de l'épidémie dans des
conditions de sûreté sanitaire et de
sécurité sanitaire qui ont été remplies
et je l'indiquais parce que ces états
européens nous ont dit leur
reconnaissance de la bonne réalisation
de ces opérations de même
c'est sur les transports et vous les
entendez dire sur l'illustration qui
vient jeu
une possibilité que ça soit moi qui suit
je ressens les mêmes
j'ai parlé en gros le mot clé si
peut-être un peu comme ça ces transferts
patients transfert location en
discussion leur transfert pour faire une
pause et le jour et la
déjà posé la question est ce par deux
hommes alors
poser la question
techniquement ces réseaux
bien sûr cette question
comédien
m
je